if I was to die today
what is it I will tell you
[Music]
maybe I could share my pain
I hope it never fails you
sit down my son
let me talk to you let your Shadow be
your best friend
on this race you run you will follow
this truth but please don't let it be
the end
don't forget to breathe take it easy
every scar that you have it will slowly
heal and that dopamine that you don't
need gonna turn your head to Stone in a
heart if I wish to die today
what is it I will tell you
y'all could share my pain
I hope it never fails you
say it's funny
on a wedding day if I was the night
today
what is it I will tell you
your brother's close
when I'm just a ghost
my bones are fading time is running
maybe something gotta let you know
[Music]
if I was to die today
what is it I will tell you
maybe I could share my pain
I hope it never fails you
when he has a lot gives it takes
what is it I will tell you
[Music]
well if I was to die today
thank you
foreign
[Applause]